hey guys is the evident Caitlyn podcast
the podcasts where we still don't know
what we're doing and that's okay today
it's gonna be another focus on YouTube I
hope it's not too much YouTube but
there's just so much going on yes our
lives it's like this is literally always
this is the you're so true there's some
stuff going on in the back end with a be
testing we're gonna be talking about how
we still don't know what we're doing
after two and a half years some common
things we've gotten right some common
things we've gotten wrong and we're
gonna pay a little bonus game at the end
yeah that I don't really know about yes
I did the research this time you think
that I'll be able to give a better intro
you know you're in we learn from people
in the past set everyone loves your
intros where you just read off our nose
I was trying not to read that's what I
did wrong I didn't just read it I tried
to like do it from my memory which is a
flawed thing oh yeah yeah okay so I
think that one thing we want to start
with is a story about how we like
finally did something where we felt like
we were real youtubers in air quotes we
like took a project and we filmed in the
public in the wild so for those of you
guys who haven't watched it we recently
released a Minecraft video where we a
Minecraft diamond pickaxe video not like
a Minecraft gaming video yes which we
also released boomer gaming we took this
pickaxe and we took it to like a public
place we went to Natural Bridge Caverns
and we filmed like a YouTube video
around other people I know it's a rare
thing and like we've taken projects into
public before but in scenarios where we
didn't have to interact with anyone and
really the only thing I can think of is
we've taken projects to a park to get
like pretty outdoor shots yeah and every
now and then we will like someone will
ask what we're doing because we have a
bench in the park and we're taking
pictures of it we've never recorded that
we've never record any interactions
while we've been out and about no you
never recorded any interactions I guess
like when the cop stopped by but that
wasn't on perfect that was not verbal
we just had to include that because like
if you're shooting a propane cannon in
the abandoned public park and a cop
comes to check on you you like the
camera that's a rule that you have to
try to film that as much as you can I
mean come on but but yeah I can't really
think of any other scenarios where we
took filming into public with like the
hope that we would get some interesting
interactions and reactions and it was
really fun I think that I was slightly
worried I might be no more like hesitant
or nervous or like I might just feel
weird about it that's what my fear was
but I didn't really feel weird about it
at all probably because we've been
filming ourselves for so long in all
these various scenarios and it didn't
feel weird and also I knew that since we
were in full control of the footage that
we would be able to blur people's faces
and like if there are any footballs on
someone else's part or whatever then you
know we could present everyone in their
best light not that there were any faux
pause but it's kind of like if we were
in a filming in public in another
scenario maybe where we weren't editing
it or what-have-you I might feel weirder
about it but I think that since you were
in control of the whole thing I just
knew that everything was gonna be okay I
don't know I have so much pain today
yeah I think um I think I would have
been more nervous and I was a little
nervous but I was I was more nervous
about them not letting us in because we
actually did try to do a similar thing
once and it didn't work out yeah but
when we did when we did our first soap
video we're like you know it'd be really
cool what if we take our soaps to Lush
which is a like fancy soap store
we're like what if we take our soaps to
lush and we ask the employees there to
ask to like tell us how we did yeah I
get a professional shoes or at least
they're not a professional someone who
is around fancy soaps a lot and we were
like that'd be so cool but being the
rule-followers that we are we
hold them at the store first and we were
like hey um so we have a YouTube channel
we weren't that hesitant we're hoping
that we've got a felt no but we did ask
if we could film yeah store cuz like it
felt weird to be sneaky about it and it
would have been weird to be seen we went
to Natural Bridge Caverns I have like a
nerd fanny pack wires running to my ears
to monitor the sound we have this big
camera like if you if we were filming in
lush especially like interviewing
someone it would be super weird if they
didn't know everything it'd be so weird
but I feel like at Natural Bridge
Caverns
everyone has their camera out people are
already taking videos and photos you
know what's so interesting so one of the
youtubers that we watch that we've
gotten some recent inspiration from is
Sofia
yes apheon a guide and she often films
at Disney World so have cameras out all
the people also have cameras and it's
not weird to have cameras it's like
people are taking pictures of other
people all the time and that's why she
goes there because there's crowds yeah
it's not weird to have a camera it's not
weird to have a camera in order to make
filming YouTube videos in public less
weird go to camera yeah that's so
interesting cuz I didn't feel weird
having the camera whereas you know it
would have been super weird they said no
by the way obviously which is why that
scene is not in these soap-making the
first the reason they said no is they're
like well we wouldn't be able to promote
a competitor's brand because but they
thought that we were trying to like sell
it or compare ours to theirs or do like
a hit piece on them or something like
that and it is an interesting thing and
it is a problem it's a problem they
don't worry about I mean Walmart has
gone so much harassment basically from
these youtubers who aren't filming in a
mature and responsible manner let's just
say yeah you know people go there and
they've done some like crazy stuff I'm
not sure if you've seen it but they've
done like they've like damaged displays
and damaged goods and like caused havoc
just to like say I got kicked out of
Walmart or you know it's like a weird
badge of honor
it's like a weird badge of honor like
they're going for the click baby
thumbnail that isn't clickbait but
they're doing
they're doing these dumb behaviors just
to get like silly footage for their
videos be respectful listen to your
elders
hey you know that might be older than us
that'd be weird but you know but yeah so
it does it does make sense that they
didn't feel comfortable with us filming
and I'm I'm so glad we called and asked
even though they said no but yeah that
is an interesting thing to think about
that this wasn't weird it wasn't weird
and now we kind of know why yeah huh
well to keep that in mind for future
things too I there's like not something
a little bit closer in Houston where we
could like easily know go and film in
public what would that be like I guess
the park I don't know I mean a lot of
our projects don't really make sense to
be taken out our propane cannon wouldn't
be weird in the least yes perfectly
acceptable it was it was a fun
experience to push ourselves in that new
direction and you know it is partially
because we have been continually
shifting like what our inspiration is we
keep all of our old parts of like the
video style that we've built up and we
keep on layering and adding new things
it's like I think that one of our very
first episodes we kind of go through all
the channels that affected us yeah we
might need to do an update episode where
we like go through the continued
evolution of all the other channels that
have inspired us in the new ways yeah
we're like thinking about filming and
thinking about how to do more like I
know that we kind of talked about
nonlinear editing when we talked about
how the try guys inspired us um but now
Sofia has inspired us even more by doing
like mixing not just nonlinear editing
of like things in the moment but like
sitting at a desk reading something or
voiceover overlaid and intermixed
between the content between like the
light with the live footage with the
live footage yeah yeah so continuing to
evolve
in other news a good transition to news
there's there some interesting
it's going on with YouTube right now and
one that we have very mixed feelings
about and by mixed I mean strongly
negatives
the only negative YouTube is
experimenting with a new layout for the
homepage it's so weird I don't
understand so big so so basically if
you've been to the YouTube homepage and
you're not just mainly on your phone you
know that there's probably like an a
layout of six to eight videos wide at
times depending on your screen but like
a whole bunch of thumbnails a whole like
you know it's all holed up into like
topics you might like or like from it'll
be like from your subscriptions or like
what working a topic or home renovation
cats you know the various things we like
to watch and now it's just like two
videos wide there's large giant and what
nails weren't meant to be that big well
but also like literally I think that
like they're they're testing a photo
before it's they're testing a feature
before it's fully implemented on the
back end because they're all really
pixelated all of the pixels are all the
thumbnails are super like stretch and
pixelated it's like they took a like
very small resolution file and just
dragged it out yeah it's so bad it's so
interesting that that is specifically
the like pixelation I'm sure that's
something it was just like a bug they're
working out but yeah I just don't like
the really big things cuz it's like you
know you do certain things to the
thumbnail because they are such a small
image like you might boost the contrast
more than you would if you were just
editing a photo yeah you might put the
text bigger than what looks nice because
you want it to just show up in a tiny
thumbnail but then when it's enlarged
like you know double the length and
double the width now let's on it's like
punching you in the face yeah I think
that one thing that I'm gonna do and I
want to be responsible person about this
YouTube needs feedback from their users
so I'm gonna find a place where I can
politely send in feedback and I will
like participate in the official process
and
send feedback on this feature because on
the back end of youtube they are always
asking us like what do you think about
this new beta feature what do you think
about this and that and on the back end
dear Sirs or Madam's this sucks
goodbye you know because it is hard to
know what to do when you're in a vacuum
of no feedback it's like I'm sure that
the amount of people who visit YouTube
every day versus the number of people
who get feedback is very small I'm sure
they're getting feedback but I bet most
of it is like people tagging them on
Twitter and some like that oh that's
hard to sort through in an official way
whereas if you leave the feedback
through official systems then they can
like quantify that I mean there's
there's a like on the creator side of
things there's a youtube channel that we
talked about before creator insider and
they're developing you know the new
back-end for content creators and you
know the people on that channel they say
every comment that a content creator
leaves on the leave feedback it's all
sorted it's all read it's all like like
that like kind of like how we read every
single comment they read every single
piece of feedback and you know it's a
much smaller number on there like our
side of things but uh it's interesting
to think about yeah let's let's
hopefully it's a democracy and we can
sway them to move in the right direction
who knows but one thing that's
interesting Google and YouTube is also a
company and this is something that I
found out that I think is very
interesting and just strange a little
bit in general YouTube is adding more
ads everywhere so if like well YouTube
and Google in general so Google in
general it's like if you're in the
assistant you know you get personalized
recommendations based on all of your
metadata and your personalized like data
about you like stories you might like
whether your commute there's also gonna
be ads you mean like the little pull
down on your phone a little pull down on
your phone the little swipe the Google
assistant I never look at this I use
that a bit so that's gonna affect me
some on Google images there's also going
to be ads
at the top when you search for business
I know is it gonna be relevant like if I
search minecraft diamond pickaxe is it
gonna be people paying to be at the top
of Minecraft diamond pickaxe or is it
gonna be like some random company I
didn't read much about this article good
research follow link the official Google
Blog Post down below with some of the
updates on the apps but the craziest
thing the thing that like affects me and
will affect people who watch our content
is on the home page of the Google mobile
app you're scrolling through videos and
there's gonna be an ad in the home feel
like Instagram like Instagram no yes and
the thing that's weird about this is
like who who gets the credit for that is
it just straight to Google is it not
it's got to be just straight to Google
this straight to Google that they're
just skimming it off the top because you
know on Google now or on YouTube it now
when if your I can add the creator's
getting someone like a small portion of
that money exactly so it's like
benefiting benefiting benefiting the the
creator community and I guess one thing
that's interesting is a lot of these
advertisers they have a lot of
hesitation about is putting their ad
before someone else's video because what
if that video is someone at Walmart
trying to get kicked out you know I mean
and then like what if there's an ad for
Walmart cuz they're like hey this title
this video has Walmart in the title
let's put a Walmart ad in front or you
know whatever it is and some some
companies might want a very safe space
but their ad yeah but at the same time
what if their ad is right above and
below yeah it's still kind of faces the
same problem but yeah this is just
interesting that uh they're kind of
moving in that direction and I again you
know with any of these products that you
get for free and air-quote yeah you are
the product your attention you're paying
with your attention yeah and they're
monetizing it via ads and and other
things so I mean that's just kind of a
way of things even one thing that's
interesting is now with YouTube premium
YouTube has been like developing these
like
premium shows like Cobra Kai and Liza ko
she has a few and now they're releasing
them ad-supported like so there used to
be exclusive to YouTube Brad and people
who pay like a subscription oh now that
you can watch them but with ads but with
ads like intermixed in them before or
after and all of that stuff so basically
now the only difference between having
YouTube Premium or regular YouTube is
just no ads with premium no ads but but
also like if you
they're also releasing everything at
once if you're on YouTube bread but if
you're on normal YouTube that like you
have to wait so like they're just doing
a lot of things because then they can
you know they're releasing it but in a
way that's kind of annoying cuz like you
have to wait and watch ads but if you
get hooked you might be willing to pay I
think one interesting thing is I think
that we're gonna title this episode of
the podcast we don't understand YouTube
and I guess one thing that's comforting
is YouTube doesn't understand YouTube
you know no one knows what's going on
it's just a big vast experience
experiment they're just like is our
livelihood is our live photos like
people at at YouTube they're just
experimenting let's try this let's try
this 1% experiment and if you guys don't
know it there's a lot of like 1%
experiments going on a lot of the time
we were we were we weren't able to talk
about it I think that we can now because
YouTube has talked about it multiple
times on their creator insider channel
like engineers at YouTube have talked
about it I think we can talk about it
generally - on their public - it's not
an NDA that says like we're not supposed
to say specifically that we were part of
it right I don't know you didn't check
that I think that it's good cuz cuz
they've talked about and other people
have talked about it there's been
articles written about it yeah yeah so
YouTube is doing like an a/b thumbnail
testing for for people who don't know
what thumbnail to choose which we we
never do we never do like with every one
of our videos we have like a few
thumbnails in the Minecraft pickaxe
we went through at least 10
main branches of the thumbnail and
within those in total we probably had
like we went through 30 iterations of
the thumbnail yeah we put a lot of time
into it because it's very important and
we've tried different things to try to
figure out what some nail is best like
we've posted on patreon or honor discord
we've shared it on our socials we've
asked our moms we we have like a thing
we got from another youtuber friend
where we can like insert it it's like a
little template where you can insert it
into a YouTube homepage and seems to
stand out you know so we've all this
very all these various things but it's
still just very hard to make that and we
we've spent up to probably eight hours
on a thumbnail just like three hours and
three hours or something like that like
that's a lot like an hour sometimes be
knocking about in less than that yeah it
all depends but yeah it's always very
hard so we were super excited to get
invited to be part of the thumbnail AV
testing program because you could do I
think up to three I think you could
maybe even do more than three options
but after a week they will let you know
which one did better yeah well what you
do is you can submit you submit your we
would always do two at a time but you
can submit your set of thumbnails they
will on the back end show like a certain
percent your thumbnail be a certain
percent your thumbnail a and then after
a week they tell you which one performed
better and you put a or you put your
though your favorite one is a cuz
they're gonna show mostly more people
that one yeah and what we learned that
literally every time B was a better
thumbnail so basically we were wrong it
wasn't every time six out of seven the B
thumbnail was better and the one time
that it wasn't better it was the same
yeah it's like oh my gosh even when we
tried to like game it there was once I
think it was with the resident ocean
bath caddy I was like you know what this
is the one I think is a and this is the
one I think is B let's reverse it yes
always wrong and then we're still wrong
it's so crazy because we even tried to
adjust yeah as we went based on a be
testing feedback that we were kind of
getting and it just kind of goes to show
that we just we've been doing this for
two and a half years we have a
saxophones Channel I you know this is a
successful channel you know and we still
don't know what's goin teresting I think
one of the reasons it's so hard is
because I mean obviously there's not
things that universally are guaranteed
to work there might be some best
practices but you know we could we could
talk to our other YouTube friends and
their strategies are totally different
than ours and wouldn't work on our
channel I think that if you have a
formula like Bon Appetit how's our
series called grapes yeah and all of
those something else are very similar
it's like the gourmet version the real
version and clear in the background yeah
so it's like if you have a formula like
that that you know works and that works
man they get views you kind of you you
you know generally what the thumbnails
gonna be yes but I think because those
videos have done so well they were just
able to say like okay let's just do the
same thing and then when people see it
they know immediately what it is but you
have to have a very formulaic tape this
video in order to be that formulaic with
your thumbnail and I don't think that
that's necessarily the best thumbnail
format I think there might even have
been a better one personally mainly just
making everything bigger like I think
it'd be better if you could see Claire's
expression a little bit better and I
think the little inset photos of the
food sometimes that's too small to
really see it mm-hmm so I think it could
be even but of course at this point it
doesn't make sense for them to change it
because they the consistency and
recognition is the most important thing
yeah it's very a fan base yeah cuz
they've like a solid fan base I know and
when you get millions of views every
time you do it like of course you don't
change it yeah you want you want to get
the you
they have a hit on their hands and they
want to keep on hitting that you know
I'm how would we if we were gonna
formalize our thumbnails what would it
be okay what could we do we need a face
in it all right I think that we need one
of our favorite things we need a face
because that's like what our channel is
kind of you know that's the thing that
that's the only thing that unifies our
channel the two of us making something
mmm my beard once I made a nice you made
my beard I made your beard you're right
yeah yeah so okay okay so bottom left
corner is my face making an expression
top right corner because you're taller
and because the bottom right is where
the timestamp that the 10th video length
is top right is your face we're both
making expressions very clickbait be
like oh oh and then in the middle is an
in-progress or a final it's a final shot
but it's pixelated every time so yeah
that'd be horrible and then arrows red
arrows and a big question mark do it
every time that'd be horrible
that'd be so bad gold that's the formula
I think that one of our strengths is
that we keep on adapting it's annoying
it's it's more work leave your
suggestions below in our YouTube video
of what our formulas should be because
we don't know more face is going oh and
would they be like this like us against
a green screen cut out yeah cut out just
cut out that's taken in post yeah we can
just honestly just use the same thing
every single time oh I think I do
horribly but but you know good attempt
what's your suggestion
my suggestion is a lot harder what we do
is okay so this is this is all I'm gonna
be a little bit realistic cuz I know
that you were kind of being like you're
kind of being a little goofy but like to
be serious about like what actually goes
into the back grill you know what goes
into our thoughts as we think of a
thumbnail
one we're like what is our current
audience want what do they expect and
how can we like appeal to our current
audience and and you know as we have
been developing our channel our audience
has kind of shifted some because we used
to just show the final shot and then the
final shot and us and then like now it's
us and an in-progress or you know so I
can have way done or a detail or like
some sort of a little bit of a tease so
that the final result isn't spoiled
before the final sometimes we do show
the final so you know part of what we're
like okay so how are we gonna peel to
our current audience how are we gonna
appeal to a new audience and who is that
new audience going to be so in the
Minecraft thumbnail for example we kind
of wanted to shout out some like
Minecraft type things that people who
like Minecraft will see it and have that
nostalgic feeling so that's why we
included the pickaxe we showed the final
thing to take accident we included a
little creeper and we included a creeper
but we also wanted to show Kate one of
our faces and so we did Caitlin's cuz it
had the best image but we also wanted to
show that we were in a cave so we chose
an image of Caitlin and the cave instead
of Caitlin in the workshop because we
thought it was more unusual and we
wanted to show that there's gonna be an
adventure and you know we're gonna move
locations and there's gonna be different
and we also wanted to show us making it
so we included a poor and that also
appeals to people who like resin who
like the build who like the like actual
and it gives us a little bit of that
like transformation from this to that
vibe from this to that by the arrow
between the poor pointing to the pickaxe
and you it makes you want to hopefully
it makes you want to see like how you
get from this step to this step yeah but
there's like all of that and more that
we think of kind of like and that's like
where we ended up in the process of
getting there we are like do we just
show just the pickaxe like next to the
pixel version of it yeah we could just
do a close-up of the pickaxe and that's
it or like the digital to the real don't
have any of our faces and just have
Minecraft to real life you know as the
main concept and that we did have
something like that and it looked
awesome
but we just were worried about what that
was
well we worried that it would it
wouldn't communicate that there was like
a strong human element to these videos
yeah you don't have a human ill a human
like in it yeah um and some people are
able to do like Bobby Duke yes because
somebody else don't usually have him in
it but also that's because his audience
is used to it now yeah his audiences
used to is now and he's big enough that
it's not gonna like affect things
negatively yeah but I mean like you know
when when we were when I was personally
looking at the photo that had just the
just the the two things and you know the
two things as in the pixel pickaxe and
the real pickaxe
yeah and I'll go ahead and link in the
description of this video all into our
blog post about this podcast where I'll
list some of the potential thumbnails so
that you guys can see what we're talking
about because it's kind of hard to just
like try to picture this in your head so
visit the blog post below if you want to
see what thumbnails we're talking about
but um I think that one of our worries
about just having the two pickaxes and
not our face is that to me is like the
in air quotes stronger YouTube thumbnail
like if it was just a generic person's
YouTube video and it was a generically
on YouTube but I was worried that it
wouldn't appeal to our current audience
it would perform much worse in the first
24 hours a week and if it doesn't do
well with your audience it probably
isn't going out to the wider YouTube
audience because your audience already
gave it a bad ranking yeah well and I
think I think when you're saying like
generic YouTube do you mean it kind of
looked like it's it looks more like a
thumbnail that would be in one of the
like life hack kind of things yeah it's
like not a person running it it's more
of like a company running it yeah and
it's kind of like a two minute video on
like yeah yeah where it's like that's
not produced in some foreign country of
some sort and like Brown Eyed Girls
reference the truth tree I'm sorry don't
look up that channel please don't go
there they don't need any more views
even if it's rage watching
what we're saying about someone else Oh
they'd be testing and how we are
terrible yeah another thing that we've
kind of been bad at is predicting what
videos would do well in what videos
wouldn't yeah sometimes we get it but I
feel like half at least half the time
we're totally off well I think that one
thing I think like you know and and you
have to be careful about drawing
conclusions when you're looking
backwards on data that you're kind of
biased on and everything because you
know you can see patterns you can get
like false positive in terms of patterns
because that's just human nature I guess
but like one of the examples we kind of
bring up is the propane cannon when we
launched it we thought oh this is going
to be super awesome because it has all
of the elements that we see in
successful YouTube videos you know what
I mean but because it was so abnormal to
our audience it didn't perform as well
and like that's what that's my
conclusion looking back on it yeah um
I'm not sure if it's right no I think
it's right I think it's what you think
is right I think it's right why do you
think the mariokart failed then because
that's another one that we thought we
was gonna do awesome and it it didn't
really I think maybe it's kind of
similar similar I think because it
wasn't as much of like a bill was too
much time spent on the like battling the
mario karts
my own car robots just for context
because we haven't brought this on it up
yet today already but we like got these
robot car kits and we like 3d printed
accessories so that we could turn them
into mario kart battle cars so we put
like razor blades on their heads and
these little 3d printed like helmets
that we made for them and then we 3d
printed little things to stick balloons
on their butts yeah and we decorated
them and made them funny-looking and
stuff it was one of the most fun things
I have done it was so fun in my life it
was so much fun in the backyard we set
up some obstacles and dabbled each other
but I think I think so much of the video
was the battling and not so much the
making and even the making wasn't as
much making we were putting together a
kit and chatting and we were
accorded it in a live stream that we
edited together we edited the live
together there's just too many unusual
things proud yeah yeah it's also
interesting because the propane cannon
eventually took off and Mario Kart has
just stayed there at like a low number
of probiem cannon we eventually did a
collaboration with modern rogue and they
kind of pointed some people to that
video and that kind of gave it a little
steroid shot and then it kind of after
their initial boost it kind of took off
again we change the thumbnail I think
and yeah so there's a lot of other
things going on but yeah we in that in
the opposite direction one that did well
that like was our number two video for
so long
drywall drywall how about Hatchin repair
drywall it was literally the second
video we have ever recorded and edited
yeah and it was it's not like a boring
thing the test of times the test of time
like and it's very different from the
videos we do now cuz it's a tutorial I
mean there's still like cute it's pretty
much a straight-up tutorial it's of
humor no added in but you know it's all
voiceover we're actually telling you
what what to do and what material is a
material like step one step two step
three oh man yeah so it's like very
different now where we kind of like go
faster and like don't get into those
details quite as much I never expected
like when we recorded that I don't even
know why we did it I think we just
needed to patch holes in our garage we
just need it well because we were we
were like okay if we're gonna be filming
in our workshop it looks like crap now
yeah the walls were so beat-up and so
bad we had one hole that was like I
could have crawled into it yeah so big
and I think her car rammed it yeah I
think that's the only explanation
it was like the size of like a backpack
so I'm just I I was looking around the
room and I saw a backpack a large
backpack it was a big hole and so we
needed to fix all that stuff and we were
when we launched our channel we wanted
to launch with like four or five videos
so we were
also trying to figure out videos we
could do to launch the channel so it's
like what we have to do this in order to
film in here and we might as well film I
need DIY content we might as well film
it so that's why we did it but we didn't
expect that it would do well yeah so
yeah we weren't expecting that at all
yeah and then I think one other thing
that surprised me a little bit is the
spin acrylic oh the spin art spin art
yeah yeah so it was so like fun and easy
and we were like this is probably music
we wanted to do that it's just because
we wanted to do that yeah but like I
didn't expect it to do well and that one
yeah kind of like kicked off our 2019
spring growth after a bit of a slump
yeah yeah and not to say like you know I
think that we're kind of pointing out
all the times we got things wrong I mean
there are some times where we really did
think that we were gonna do well and
they did well like the self water and
concrete resin planter yeah like we
really wanted to do that to perform well
and it did perform well same as catio
asked the three top ones we had high
hopes for and then and the Geo tape our
top 5 were things that we were like
these are gonna do well and they did
well pat you on the back here can I get
some yeah see it's not weird if we're
patting each other on the back yeah yeah
but there are some things we get wrong
but I think the main point is I don't
really know what the main point of this
episode is but we don't know what we're
doing but also nobody knows well III
know no III know where I wanted to get
to with this episode I what kind of
wanted to get to a point okay the point
is how do we feel okay with things at
the end of the day and like at the end
of the video when that when the video
performs however it performs how do we
feel good about what we've done and I
think that the conclusion I've gotten to
is as long as we feel like we did
everything we could for the video even
if it does poorly we're like okay we did
we tried we did everything we could
and and there's no regrets yeah I mean
like of course like we kind of do have
regrets about like oh I wish it had done
better it's not really regrets it's like
you you wish things had gone otherwise
but I think it's not I think regrets
isn't the right word yeah I think it's
but but I think you're right I think one
thing that we've gotten a little bit
better about recently is like making
sure that we're thinking through our
thumbnail and title choices like from
the perspective of okay when we launched
this if it does poorly are we gonna be
scrambling last minute to change it or
have we already thought of all the
things that'll be running through our
heads
and there have been many times where we
scramble that's the worst when you
launch something and then you're like
crap this this thumbnail is crap this
title it's terrible we got to change it
now what to be changes here oh my god
I'm trying to Photoshop so fast was the
the nail flail yeah that was the most
rest you've ever been you're like
freaking out that was the zombie weapon
which did not perform as well as we
thought it was so fine looks fine but we
said it wouldn't do really well and I
think it's I think some of it if you
look at um the zombie weapon the propane
cannon and the mario kart battle they're
all weapons okay they're all weapons
maybe YouTube suppress them I think
those are three of the most fun videos
that we've had in terms of practical
no no that's know what I mean it's it's
some of the most fun we've had filming
yeah with some of those videos and I
think because we have such a fun time
filming we think people are gonna have
fun time watching us been such a fun
project it's gonna do so well you know
it's interesting I I do have to say some
people who have watched are those videos
have said it's the favorite they've it's
their favorite - that's true I'm not
gonna say that they're my favorite I
just think there's some of the most fun
that we've filmed just cuz it's like you
know smashing and fruit with a flail you
made and shooting watermelons
ramming razorblade adorned robots into
each other is very fun it's very fun
yeah but it is hard to know how things
are gonna perform I trying to see into
the future
speaking of which smooth transition here
I was on ask reddit the other day arm
and there is a question asked there that
I wanted to bring up to you so is this
thing is this the game this is kind of a
game I'm not sure if it's a game we
might be able to turn it into a game
somehow but I'm just gonna ask you and I
just want to like discuss things with
you so if you had access to YouTube from
the year 2050 but you could only browse
it for one hour
what would you search for and what would
you watch so so like all of a sudden
your YouTube like app on your phone goes
through a time warp and you can just
like browse only YouTube like our
Channel and see if it still exists one
of my first thoughts - and then like see
what the top-performing videos were and
then just do those earlier earlier yeah
you know I think there is benefit in
looking at other channels but you know
just like right now I could I could look
at some of the top performing videos and
know that they're not things I would
want to do or things that would do well
on our channel so i would i would look
at our channel in 50 years i would also
look at some of our favorite channels so
you wouldn't like research like the
history of like sports and all the
surprising upturns and then write that
all down and then make bets and earn a
lot of money or top performing companies
and cheap the stock market not as
interesting yeah I mean I guess I wasn't
thinking about that house I was thinking
like how to use it to our advantage in
YouTube not like I see what trend other
thing that we could do is we could like
look at what trends are about to blow up
yeah in various years and then like we
know that when that trend starts
happening we will have a video ready to
release like right as it's like about to
blow up and then we get to blow up with
it instead of reacting to thing this one
thing that I thought that's interesting
you see
I'll look at what videos did well for us
and do them in advance but I think the
thing that's hard about that is the
videos that do well in our future might
only do well because we did all the
videos leading up to them that's true
well I could look at the ones in the
future that didn't do well and be like
you're right about that you're right
about those and go to the next and then
you still generally though I mean I feel
like this is kind of like I not taking
full advantage of this YouTube in 2050 I
mean we could like I'm getting we could
like screen record it like look up the
news and natural disasters and like
prevent natural disasters or something
like that I mean that's noble sounding
but like I can't prevent a hurricane
yeah but we can evacuate the city we
could we can make a youtube video and we
could like oh you know we can do oh oh
oh I know screen record your phone the
whole time and Google search at all and
then make a video about all the videos
that you search and then that will go
super viral and everyone will watch that
video of yours and we and we can do so
much good and also benefit from it I
mean that's a great idea and then would
be famous because we look up things in
the future and then yeah you get that
one time and then all you do is you
record it all and then as those things
start becoming true people will believe
you because at first people are gonna be
like nah nah I feel like that video
wouldn't do super well on our channel I
don't think our audience is expecting
that type of video we'd have to make a
project based around it by the way we
also discovered that our phone went
through a time-space continuum in and
they recorded that knows you too
by the way yeah that is interesting to
think about I guess it's like I have
slight interests alright I do have
interest in learning that type of stuff
but I don't know if I have enough
interest to like really put in all the
effort needed to fully cheat the system
you know what I mean yeah like in terms
of like looking up what's gonna do well
in the stocks I'd be like you think a
man would be like top cat videos of 2050
you you'd be tempted like IV too
paranoid to try to like cheat this stock
system even if like no one knew that I
had this on my phone I feel like someone
would find out that I had insider
information and then they'd go after you
laughed you might be true about that
yeah because I would have insider
information cuz Caitlyn like really
especially like in in school and stuff
Kaelin was like nothin though you don't
even you don't even get close to the
line of the room you say way over there
yes and you get straight A's yes did you
ever get a B in school like in a class
yeah I got one be really nice girl are
you upset
I was upset but it was my second my last
semester senior year oh it was a like
college credit course oh yeah it was
harder but I still got the credit even
with the B know so you got all the
advantage anyways yeah yeah and I
already like knew where I was going to
school and everything so it didn't
really matter that much that was my
version of like senior slacking I got a
B in one class well I think that that
wraps up the the bonus topic I'm not
really sure where I was going with that
I just had a trial I could random thing
thrown answers some of the answers were
everything that you'd think about like
how to how to cheat like the the like
economy how to like look up inventions
look up like technology stocks socks
it's a it's a meme thing it's stocks
oh you're very cool I just like I just
spend too much time I read it at times
and read it has its own brand of humor
well I understand that I spend a lot of
time on reddit - yeah you do you're cool
Thanks stocks yeah there's just a lot of
things with people like wanting to game
the system and stuff like that that's
interesting cuz it I wonder um I feel
like the answers might be different if
you're asking someone who is you know
who's a youtuber mm-hm versus someone
who's not a youtuber because somebody's
not a youtuber that there's no reason
for them to look up like what's gonna
trend in terms of like wanting to make a
video on it yeah but like imagine if you
had have known that fidget spinners
we're gonna blow up I know but and then
you could like buy the fidget spinner
company take out a loan by the fidgets
spinner company and become the fidget
spinner company and ride that way for a
year yes but that's different that it's
different
cuz that's different than being like oh
I'm gonna mix all the fidgets spinner
videos mm-hmm yeah like the motives
different yeah you could yeah cuz most
of my initial thoughts were like how can
I use this to the advantage of our
channel not like how can I make money in
another way that's not the channel you
know what this kind of goes back to
something we've talked about before and
I don't wanna like repeat myself but
I'll just touch on it briefly one
interesting and dangerous thing is if we
had of like let's say we had have known
that fidget spinners were gonna blow up
and that slime was gonna blow up if we
had have known that would we have done
it like beforehand beforehand because at
first
my instinct was yes but now that I'm
thinking about a little bit more I'm
like no cuz then what does have a whole
bunch of people who want fidget spinner
videos and slime videos I think if you
just do like one yeah you're not trapped
in it you just have one video that
really well yeah you know and I think
there's ways like we've seen other
people in the maker community do that
kind of thing but make it their own like
DP make stuff made a giant wooden fidget
spinner that was all out of solid wood
wood ball bearings everything it's super
cool still very maker II something and
tying into the pizza spinner like like
even people who hate fidget spinners
have a V like wrists
fact yeah exactly I feel like we could
have done something like that we didn't
do anything with the fidgets spinners or
slime or that kind of thing but I feel
like we could have figured out something
to still make it feel like this I think
that another a thing that kind of hit me
when I was thinking about if we could
see you know 30 years in the future and
look at whatever our - what our top
videos were I think I'd be really boring
to make those video yeah really some
things the process is fun no matter what
yeah I think this goes back to my pet
peeve of like repeating work even though
I didn't do it well I I knew that I
liked well then what's the alternative
purposely avoiding that if we could see
in the future now would have to do it
yeah at least do like so yeah just some
of it just a little bit it's like nope I
don't like that direction I'm going this
way all right yeah but I think that's a
good place to wrap up the topic and
we'll we'll transition smoothly into
thing of the week
my thing of the week is my slow descent
into madness that is RGB everything I've
just I just really like RGB things guys
I think that it's ever since we started
the gaming channel yeah I kind of blame
that slightly it started maybe with this
desk and having the RGB right it started
with the desk in the desk and then and
then it's been a slow descent into RGB
obsession keyboards RGB mouse pads RGB
computer bulbs
RGB mouse pads that's what my thing of
the week is yeah and it's not just a
mouse pad it's a mouse and keyboard pad
it's why I think it's wide enough that
you can put your mouse and keyboard on
it well the thing that always annoyed me
is I wanted to shift my keyboard around
but my mouse pad kept on interfering
with it you know my keyboard would like
lift up on an edge and like you don't
think that an eighth of an inch
difference from one side of keyboard to
the other would be annoying but it's
terrible especially for people at their
desks for so much of the day so I got a
giant mouse pad this as why that's like
it also kind of works is like like a
little cushion for your wrists yeah it's
kind of cushy it's a more cushy material
and it also has RGB all the way around
the sides and one thing that I thought
was really unique about this one I saw a
few that didn't have it I chose this
specifically because it has it because
it's RGB it has to be powered and is
powered over USB and as long as you're
have us be coming to your desk they have
a USB port on the side of the mousepad
so yeah that's that ping is and if you
want to plug in like a flash drive you
can plug it into your mouth pads report
on your mousepad
I think it's meant to like for your
mouse so you can plug your mouse and
yeah you know which I think is yeah plug
in our SD card reader I'm not sure with
USB 3.0 but it's still kind of a neat
little feature so that's the thing that
I've liked now I do have to say as soon
as you unwrap it from the package
because it comes in the tube it does
take a little bit to settle out the
wonks of it but I thought something
that's something I noticed on like every
mousepad how's that because they don't
want to ship in giant boxes so every
mouse to have this wrap in a tube and it
probably sits in warehouse for like six
months or whatever but my eventually
settled out yeah I didn't take that
didn't take that long I kind of like
bent it a little bit and then let it
settle but I've been enjoying it it's
being a GB I don't know if you guys can
tell in the video of this but we are
testing out a thing it's personal Erie
gaming channel but we here we test on
the podcast video to where we have our
like RGB color changing light bulbs next
to us go really coordinated that was
like Evans got kind of like a blue light
on him right now and I've kind of a red
light on me and it's really just for the
benefit of the people watching the
YouTube video sorry audio listeners make
more sense on the gaming channel but it
makes me feel super legit it makes it
feel like professional podcaster dude
man yeah so my thing the week is it's a
faux trailer that I wish was real like
it makes me so happy and so sad to watch
so happy it is a Zelda and Studio Ghibli
crossover trailer yeah so basically this
person there's one person an animator
and an amazing artist who who likes
Studio Ghibli and like Zelda basically
made a like trailer for a Zelda movie if
Studio Ghibli made it so it's all in the
style of Studio Ghibli but like all of
the characters Zelda character Zelda
locations and like watching it just
makes me so happy so nostalgic and but
it also makes me so sad that that's not
a real thing the crossover in my like
you know that Ghibli can do it you know
you know they could they'll be beautiful
I want it oh yeah it's like I would pay
a lot of money more than like normal
tickets you start a Kickstarter
bug they can't cuz the Kickstarter
doesn't have IP no bleep I know I got a
petition
yeah petition yes let's get like a
million signatures on this
out of that petition I make a few
accounts yes all my accounts all my
accounts and if you want to check that
out we'll have a link below
magic magical prepare to be enchanted
and if you are sad that it it doesn't
exist but you want a consolation prize
on his website he also has 4k wallpapers
of art that he did yeah yeah that's nice
alright guys thanks so much for hanging
out with us I hope you enjoyed this
podcast as we figure things out and
[Music]